alright guys I'm here with Sergey I'm
super excited talking about smart
contracts today with much of the work
you've done thank you for coming
yeah thank you very much for having me
sure what um let's go to your background
real quick so that everyone kind of
knows the perspective you're coming from
that we can kind of jump into a sum of
projects you're working on and how smart
contracts will be implemented throughout
the world yeah of course makes sense so
we've been building smart contracts for
about five years some of the better work
we've done has been at smart contract
comm and we've done that work with many
different you know banks insurance
companies forward-looking mid-level kind
of also insurance companies banks
basically people who deal with financial
contracts and we've gained some
perspective on what they're actually
useful for so they're not they're not
opinion not useful for everything under
the Sun they're useful for very specific
cases where the unique properties of a
smart contract are immediately useful
usually those properties are along the
lines of creating trust or reliability
before we started building smart
contracts about five years ago in 13 in
in about 13 14 we well I was doing some
mining that's how I initially got into
the space because you know two years in
2011 when I when I got more interested
and actually started putting time and
effort towards towards cryptocurrency
back then that's all you could really do
is mine or sell or you could have some
kind of e-commerce business selling
anything for for Bitcoin or one of the
few old coins that seemed reliable so
yeah so I mean the real the real focus
for us and our team has been on making
smart contracts something useful for
real-world use cases and that ended up
meaning going towards the going towards
the places where digital agreements and
financial contracts kind of coincide
that yeah so that's that's basically
where where we started doing a lot of
work in the process of doing work of
making real world actual value
generating smart contracts we ran into
one or one or two limitations of the
space the limitation that we thought was
most pressing was a limitation around
providing data into a contract so that
limitation before we get into that what
is a smart contract oh yeah of course
yeah I think about this you know I say
so let's explain everyone what a smart
contract is to start sure so a smart
contract is you know from a semantic
perspective it's not named in the best
way probably but essentially it's a
deterministic digital agreement so it's
really it's deterministic reliable
tamper proof all of these are synonyms
depending on the vertical that you're
that you're applying the technology to
so that the unique property of a smart
contract is that it's a digital
agreement that provides determinism it
provides a guarantee that the code will
be executed as written it's basically
something that you and I if we enter
into any sort of smart contract
transaction we both agree on what is
going to happen based on a set of
parameters and then we write it into
code and if those parameters occur right
then
the code is executor of the contract is
executed yeah that's right it's it's
different from traditional digital
agreements traditional I think it's
important to just highlight the
difference so the difference is that
traditional digital agreements are
probabilistic so that means that even if
performance occurs even if there's an
extreme amount of proof of performance
that somebody could still decide not to
fulfill their obligations right this is
a bad actor well a bad actor yeah yeah I
guess you could call them about actor
it's just one of the counterparties
decides I'm not gonna fulfill minded the
agreement I would rather go to court or
I would rather you know rely on some
other mechanism in relation to how I
feel or don't fulfill this agreement
like this happens in insurance right an
insurance and insurable event occurs but
you
get paid right the policy doesn't pay
you in derivatives it happens where
settlement doesn't happen or importantly
it doesn't happen when it should happen
and there's a lot of money at stake
that's important because you lose money
if it if it moves between parties too
slowly in other situations like trade
finance sometimes people don't get paid
for delivering goods and and other other
similar similar situations so it's it's
those situations where the probabilistic
nature of today's digital agreements in
that you know regardless of how well you
code them or how good the software
running them is it they're still
probabilistic they still rely on on on
the one of the parties to decide yeah
you know I am gonna pay you on time or I
am gonna pay you at all or at where I am
gonna fulfill my my end of the of the of
the contract and so in these smart
contracts really what you need to do is
you have two or more parties come to an
agreement it's written into code and
then you need to understand what those
parameters are normally those parameters
involve some sort of data coming into
the contract so that the contract has
the information to know to execute or
not but one of the things that you've
been spending a lot of time on is
where's that data coming from what high
quality is that data how can you ensure
the validity of that data maybe just
talk through some of the data feeds that
go into these smart contracts and why
that's a problem in some of the the
existing projects or blockchains right
so that that was the big limiting factor
that that we came upon when we started
making more and more interest in
contracts so contracts that provide more
and more value then give me an example
one of those really complex ones that
you ran into a problem so for example
let's say you want to insure a shipment
of some kind of frozen meat or some
frozen goods okay so I'm the insurer
you're the you're the shipper and you
say I'm gonna ship from point A to point
B frozen meat and I say I will provide
you insurance right on that for some
cost right okay I'll make sure you're
covered as long as I have proof right
and instead of managing
the results of that somehow through
paper or some other way you can have
data from the AAS GPS of a container
ship you can have data from the IOT
devices reading temperature in the
container and you can have data about
whether something has cleared customs
and border protection okay so there's
the three data feats we'll use to know
that you did what you said you were
gonna do right so those those three do
this this is a good example because it
illustrates an incremental incremental
performance realistically in the more
academic sense of what we're doing we're
we're trying to make these complete
contracts that are complete because they
are triggered by data and because both
parties free pre determined that a data
feed is data feed X is a accurate if
data feed X shows that something has
happened then that's it they don't need
to call each other they don't need to
spend resources to verify anything the
contract can programmatically result in
in the next step all right so that's
that's really the goal and there's
there's a few dimensions to that go
one-dimensional to that goal does there
need to be data feeds and those data
feeds need to be provided to the
contract another dimension is the
contract needs to be reliable enough
that doing all of this creates enough
value that if if all of this happens
then the next day stage in the contract
actually does happen right so the the
piece that smart contract infrastructure
provides today is it provides that piece
of being able to do a state change it
provides the piece that says you know on
aetherium or or whatever other network
how do I go from state a to state B and
how do I store that state change in in
an environment basically in in a data
structure or or or in a network in the
case of smart contracts that it's it's
so reliable that the other party can
drive their own systems off it can use
it for record-keeping do all those
things so that that piece is built and
well it's built and is getting better
and better that piece is right now
getting used for tokenization okay so
the reason is getting used for
tokenization is because that's the out
of the box functionality
so out of the box you open up a smart
contract network or you use the mean net
network and you have the ability to
tokenize and move tokens and have
ownership and do all those things I mean
realistically I think that's why there's
such a focus onto organization because
it's it's the actual functionality you
can actually use today right it's kind
of it's kind of like the email of
blockchains sort of if you were to draw
an analogy it's the initial news case
that's that you that you kind of have
out of almost have out of the box now
what what we're trying to achieve in
what we've been trying to achieve for
years is to take these state changes and
tie them to real-world events because we
feel that tying them to real-world
events is where 80 to 90 percent of
digital agreements actually happen so
there's only a certain dessert in a
small percentage of agreements that
relate to purely ownership that really
purely to I'm gonna transfer token aid
you know to person to person Z over
their writing and I'm gonna transfer
token B to another person I mean that
that's useful and it's absolutely a
worthwhile improvement but it's maybe 10
to 20 percent of all of all digital
agreements and that's probably even
being generous
the vast majority of digital agreements
today they react data so they react to
some type of performance beyond asset
movement now basically basically if we
want smart contracts to compete with
these other digital agreements because
smart contracts they have the capacity
to be the I think the dominant form of
digital agreement because this property
of determinism and this property of
reliability and tamper proof myths and
cybersecurity like these properties are
are very important and very and they're
completely unique to the smart contract
so smart contracts have this property
and I think at the end of the day that
can let them become the dominant form of
digital agreement what what they don't
have in order
to be competitive is they don't have the
the ability to be as useful as a
centralized digital agreement so
centralized digital agreement can access
a data feed it can use a payment system
to pay people in you know multiple fiat
currencies it can you know it can
acquire a consent it can send a message
to a bank back-end or or startups
back-end to tell a system something
that's happened since I think they're
really important key key point to
understand from a technical perspective
is the reason that this problem exists
is that the very thing that makes smart
contracts secure the consensus that
secures that state which we want to be
highly secure in hire and to be highly
reliable that consensus among many node
operators it doesn't allow for any of
those node operators to be the source of
inputs so doesn't it doesn't have the
capacity to designate one of those node
operators as the one like you can't
write into an etherium contract to go
give me a data feed and then one of the
theory of node operators goes and gets
you that data feed that that just isn't
how it works it isn't how it's going to
work because there's various security
holes you have all kinds of various
problems with consensus that just are
not are not manageable and so how do we
solve that problem today right this idea
that smart contracts need data feeds in
more complex situations but none of the
node operators are eligible or able to
go get that data and feed it into the
smart contract right so the way the way
to solve that is you have a designated
third party that's that's designated to
be the the the unique separate node
operator called an Oracle okay so this
is important because I think a lot of
people hear the word Oracle thrown
around and crypto but they don't
actually know what that means and so
when you talk about an Oracle we've got
the smart contract which is software
code that is written it relies on nodes
right which is kind of another party if
you will in this transaction but now
there's a third party which is an Oracle
that is responsible for doing what
right so with the with the Oracles
responsible for doing is basically
receiving requests in some form
receiving a request from the requesting
contract and then fulfilling that
request usually for data or some kind of
trigger or some you know maybe the
Oracles supposed to do something out in
the real world and then report back okay
so a smart contract is basically sitting
there and it says in order to know when
to execute or if to execute
I need data the nodes that I interact
with cannot do that right yep and so
instead I need to basically ping this
Oracle to go do that and so the smart
contract says the Oracle go get me the
data feed so let's go back to our
shipping example it says get me the GPS
data
get me the data from customs etc the
Oracle just pings a data servicing gets
it or walk us through how does the
Oracle actually operate and go get the
data feeds that the smart contract needs
so so the way most Oracle's are built
right now in this and this varies
between chains but the way they it works
for most chains right now is that you
have an on chain contract that is kind
of the interface that on chain contract
is the Oracles contract and that
Oracle's contract is then sent us well
in our system our system is called chain
link so in our system you have a service
agreement going from the requesting
contract and that service agreement
defines the relationship between the
requesting contract and this chain link
slash Oracle contract right okay that
chain link slash Oracle contract
receives the request and then it can
decide in our system in chain link it
decides if I'm going to commit to
fulfilling that request once it commits
to fulfilling that request then it's
basically on the hook for performance so
give me an example or our criteria for
why would the Oracle not fulfill the
request
well that begins to go into questions of
how complex the service agreement is for
example I could send the service
agreement to an Oracle that asks them to
provide you with the data feed they
don't have access to okay
so basically as long as you are asking
the Oracle if you're the smart
contractor you ask the Oracle
for data that they're supposed to give
you that they have access to and you
don't make any kind of out-of-the-box
request the Oracle shouldn't fulfill it
well not not exactly there's also a
price that you say you're going to pay
okay and in our system in chain-linked
there's a system of deposits that that
the Oracle provider puts up to guarantee
their fulfillment of the delivery of the
data so there's there's many different
nuances so the the service agreement is
actually going to differ
based on the industry because different
industries we want different guarantees
from their Oracle's right so so part of
our body of work is actually making
making the framework where people can
thought can can request a certain degree
of security guarantees from the Oracle
right and those security guarantees can
be I want multiple Oracle's to validate
an input because I want to apply
decentralization because that's you know
that's the security model of our space
we trust the smart contract because it's
basically decentralized it's run with a
high degree of redundancy and so I mean
one of the core pieces of our of our
thesis is that you should be able to
purchase a certain degree of reliability
and redundancy in in the amount of in in
the in the providing of data to trigger
to your contract so one of one of the
key I mean one of them once once you
understand the fact that smart contracts
in these networks need an Oracle they
can't they can't go beyond tokenization
towards insurance or derivative to trade
finance or any of these industries
without an Oracle then then you begin to
think about okay well why should I rely
on this Oracle because in in the case of
smart contracts the the model of smart
contracts the security model in the
threat model and the reliability model
is so very different than digital
agreements in traditional digital
agreements there's a bunch of fallback
methods there's a bunch of ways to roll
things back and fix things and in all
kinds of you know fallback mechanisms in
in the case of smart contracts the fact
that they're so deterministic and the
fact that they're so reliable basically
basically makes it so that you also need
to trigger them with something reliable
right if you if you don't trigger it if
you have a highly reliable piece in the
middle then nobody nobody really well
people care but what people really care
about what the CEOs that lead architects
all the people that are actually going
to be building high quality financial
agreements and and the great crypto
starts and all those folks they care
about any to end security right it
doesn't it doesn't really matter if the
middle part of your contract is super
reliable if it's triggered in a manner
that's easily gained or easily broken
then the whole contract is what's but
it's the belief that you're only as
secure as your weakest Boehner ability
well yes and the idea is that in the
case of a deterministic digital
agreement mm-hmm that's immutable and
that's very difficult to make changes to
later on that's particularly important
because with that determinism you get
efficiency but with that efficiency you
you also get you know you get a lack of
fallback systems it's just it's just a
logical trade-off and so you should
really make sure that the the way in
which all these contracts function end
to end is is providing the reliability
that that would justify people people
putting actual large amounts okay and so
let's talk about Oracle's in terms of if
I'm a smart contract and I decide that I
want to enter to one of these service
agreements with an Oracle how do I
select who is the Oracle right who's
responsible for who's running it which
Oracle to use and can I create the
Oracle myself or does it need to be a
third party
okay so there's just a few a few
different nuances there one of the first
nuances is a thing to understand how the
world looks today and the problems it
has okay and how that how that can be
improved upon and then to to how you
select Oracle's in a more logical manner
so today in today you don't really have
a great Oracle service out there
what you have is centralized Oracle
services run by you know small groups of
people and most of those are closed
source and and the fact that they're
closed source creates a lot of problems
because you can't you can't validate the
quality or the reliability that they're
providing right you can't know that
they're their method of providing data
to you is as secure as the contract
write extensively so that's one problem
one other problem is they're these there
are these individual small groups of
people that you're basically trusting to
trigger tens and for hundreds of
millions of dollars in value or protects
really that just doesn't really really
make sense right what what chi-ling
seeks to do is it seeks to basically
solve that problem by generating but by
making a framework through which other
people can run these Oracle's so the got
out kind of like an AWS for Oracle's
well the the real the real way to think
about it is it's I mean the logical way
to think about it I think is that you're
mining inputs so if you if you if you're
if you're a miner in a main chain you're
mining the consensus and the state
changes of that main chain and we're if
you're running a chain link node then
you're essentially mining inputs into
that chain so people are paying you to
generate a certain type of transaction
that you're putting into the chain so
the the point being that if if you if
you just want one you don't want you
don't want five guys in the basement
with a closed source piece of software
to trigger your billion-dollar smart
contract that just logically speaking
doesn't doesn't seem to add up what adds
up more is that okay here I have you
know three five or ten independently run
nodes those independently run nodes have
a piece of software that's been reviewed
by a security researcher community by
you know but by by tens or hundreds of
developers just like the networks that
are actually running my contract
right so providing those guarantees is
is really the first step then then the
next step is okay I can select multiple
Oracle's right if I want to pay so I I'm
willing to pay for the reliability of
the contract right I'm willing to pay
for this state change to be secured by
hundreds or thousands of people and
today I'm willing to pay a premium for
it because well supposedly I I valued
that state change being so reliable and
deterministic so if you extend that
logic to to the reliability of these
Oracle's then you that logic should
continue to yes I'm willing to pay for
triggering the contract reliably then we
arrive at the question of what is what
does that mean from how much how many
Oracle's provide you what degree of
security and so how many how many
individual independent note operators
provide you a greater degree of security
this is slightly it's an unsolved
question I mean if you talk to a lot of
the smartest people out there and I
Kadima at the top universities and you
know we talk and work with them on a
regular basis it's still a question
that's being answered but but they the
important thing we think is that at this
stage there's a mechanism by which
somebody can say here's why I you can
rely on my contract here's why you can
rely on the triggering mechanism so okay
now we have the ability to select
multiple independent nodes running a
software that's been audited and is
considered to be relatively secure then
we get into the question of how do I
accurately assess which nodes which node
operators I should rely on this goes
into questions of reputation so this
goes into questions of what has been
their past performance whose contracts
have they serviced you know you know the
benefit the really positive thing about
this system is that both the the service
agreement between the requesting
contract and the chain link contract the
Oracle contract is on chain the
commitment to that contract is unchain
and the performance is unchain so unlike
other other systems all parts of the
contract are in this environment one
environment in all parts of the contract
have a cost associated with them so so
basically
what we think you you you would look at
as you would look at I have here's a
note operator he has thousands of
contracts executed with you know these
top five banks and these top ten
startups and those you know 50 other
great companies and they have he puts up
large deposits you know to guarantee his
reliability he has a very good track
record you know and then and then there
can be other forms of proof that that
note operator can provide to say I'm in
the business of delivering this data to
you live reliably here's proof that I'm
running the rec software here's all the
proof that I fulfilled previous
commitments to two contracts requesting
this data from me or requesting me to
execute a payment or to do whatever
whatever services of collection of
services I'm offering and and yes that
that is that we think is the method by
which people people would choose these
operators and then the operators would
better security guarantees would be able
to charge a premium for that and
operators with less security guarantees
I mean they charge less of a premium but
perhaps the the security model some
people might have would be maybe I use
premium operators for certain things and
I then I use a large collection of less
security guaranteed but more note
operators for other operations right the
these are the unknown but very
interesting questions for sure that
we're practically solving of kind of how
yeah so we're very interested to see how
this evolves kind of what what degree of
decentralization do people actually want
to pay for once they have the choice of
you know what degree what amount of the
centralization do I want to buy what
quality per note operator oh let me ask
you this question go to the ultimate
bowl case for smart contracts right
let's go out 10 20 30 years
can smart contracts automate every
contract in the world I mean or how big
can smart contracts be how impactful can
it be in the world I mean in in my
personal opinion I think I mean you
can't even burn all the contracts in the
world I think eventually there will be a
network effect and there will be enough
value in that for example imagine if
everybody's revenue was passed to a
smart contract and no taxes were
automatically deducted her or whatever
whatever other regulatory matters were
order or automatically solved without
any any need for even a person to be
involved right like that's just a way
more efficient way more productive way
of way of working
that's decades right that's that's when
governments begin to mandate that people
do business in a way that guarantees
that they're fulfilling all their
obligations to both governments and
counterparties right so in in in in
decades time it's probable that I mean
it's not likely we're going to be going
more towards paper right we're gonna be
going more towards digital agreements
then the question becomes what is the
dominant what is the best type of
digital agreement people can have today
it's it's smart contracts because
they're the only ones that have this
unique property of determinism and
reliability and data transfer in
cybersecurity all these key properties
the properties they don't have or
certain properties around you know some
privacy dynamics certain scalability
questions and the most immediate thing
they don't have is the ability to
meaningfully interact with the real
world the way that the traditional
agreements they're trying to replace do
right so what but all of those all of
those additional features are completely
solvable problems the the the
traditional digital agreements they
can't acquire the unique properties of a
smart contract whereas the smart
contract can acquire all the features of
these traditional digital agreements so
I mean if we're saying
I I have every reason to believe that
contracts are going more and more
digital even even beyond EC course of
course yeah I mean that's just like at
this point maybe 30 years ago it wasn't
and of course today it's just an of
course if it's an of course then that
could it could be every contract in the
world I mean eventually there would be
value right I mean if we if we think
about it there's certain contracts where
I don't think you need a smart contract
because it doesn't so this is gonna be
my argument is that every contract that
should be digital or a smart contract
will become a smart country doesn't mean
every single one needs to be that I
think eventually they'll just be there
will just be network effects like a
certain point you're forced to use
certain services as a consumer because
other people are on that service and so
I'm like I might be doing some kind of
business where I have no trust issues I
have no no need for these guarantees but
perhaps my consumer has has prior has
the control of a private key or perhaps
one of the operations my digital
agreement needs to do needs to happen in
a smart contract Network for payments
release or for data transfer for
something else at that point I'm you
know it does just network effects the
more data the more digital state the
more payments capabilities move into
these systems the more it brings along
all the other systems that need to use
those capabilities so it's not I mean
it's not an overnight process if you're
asking me about the terminal end state
scenario yeah I mean the end state
scenario is that all the if this is the
best way to do digital agreements then
you know encompass initially the the
types of digital agreements that need
this unique capability and then
eventually the cost of running your
digital agreement this way will be so
low that it'll it'll just be how they're
done I mean realistically to think about
it I mean one of the most exciting
exciting things for me personally will
be you know let's say somebody wants to
start an insurance company or somebody
wants to form some kind of company or
some kind of even just a contract that
requires a
actual back-end mm-hmm like today if I
want to form an insurance company in a
part of the world where the legal
environment might not enforce the
insurance policies I'm out of luck
right but I think what'll end up
happening is you'll have all of these
people writing all kinds of code that
represents contractual back-end backends
that code will continue to get better
and better just like open-source to
open-source software did and it just
remove the uncertainty yeah it ends up
removing removing removing the the
uncertainty assuming that all the other
pieces like the private key management
pieces in place the ability for the
contract to reliably get access to data
the ability for the contract to pay so
just to be clear we we deal with both
the reliability of inputs which are
usually data various data for market
rates to IOT to various data triggers of
contract who and as well as the outputs
so we also deal with how does you know
what software should you run if you or
or or what Oracle or what chain line
should you talk to if you want to do a
payment in another chain or in in
traditional payments environment using
banks or something else like that so
although all we basically well we
focused on making the software that
makes that possible and then there needs
to be an economic model through which
people being good miners good good good
chain lymphnode operators are are making
a very very good business out of that so
that that needs to exist so that as well
people provide that service so let's do
a quick rapid-fire a question before we
wrap up other than your company what do
you think is the most important company
in crypto the most important company in
crypto
I wouldn't I wouldn't say it's income
like I would probably go towards project
okay
and in terms of of the project that
other than our company of course but
yeah the company that I think has has
been making great strides is I mean it's
really between Bitcoin and a Syrian
still yep I mean that's that's it at the
end of the day thing is a great answer
and she's choosing between those two is
is difficult but if I had to choose one
I would probably go with aetherium
because I mean there's they're pushing
the limits of what can be done
that's what turbos keep what's your most
controversial thought what do you
believe that a high majority of other
people disagree with you on
I don't know if I have that well I think
this the adoption of smart contracts is
I thought I consistently push that that
people people I don't know if they're
surprised if it's controversial they
just need a clear explanation as to why
it's going to evolved that way I think I
think one of the more interesting
thoughts that or the conversations that
I've had recently as I've consistently
been thinking why people from other
spaces like consumer or other spaces
don't see as much value in in smart
contracts and in Bitcoin and in these
systems and I think that's that's a
misunderstanding and what this
technology does so I think and I don't
know if this is a controversial talk but
it's I think it's read believe it
relatively interesting interesting one
is that the model that people see from
the internet is that they received an
interface and that new interface created
a new purchasing dynamic with with large
large group of consumers which replaced
an old purchasing dynamic which which
made these massive companies like Amazon
and eBay and all these companies that
that participated in basically having
the right interface the right user
experience interface this this evolution
of the internet into into like what
people still sometimes call an Internet
of contracts or a new piece of the
internet emerging this internet of
contracts it it doesn't exactly have
that so it it's a very back-end heavy
problem and so to appreciate a back-end
heavy problem and the significance of a
back-end heavy problem you have to know
what back-end problems are being solved
so over the years if that yet that
technical understanding of the problem
to appreciate the significance and and
kind of gravity of it and if there's a
solution right so this is I mean this is
what I consistent consistently sees over
over the you know the years the many
years that we've been working on smart
contracts I think that many of the
people that work and consumer related
things and this is why I think a lot of
people still might not fully see the
value of this but eventually
I'm sure I'm sure that they will at
least myself personally is that you know
if you work on their on transferring
photo files and and and you're being
talk to you about a problem related to
insurance contracts or or these
financial backends or these financial
contracts it doesn't it doesn't resonate
with you you don't you don't know what
the extent of the problem works you you
you can see very clearly that there's a
there's an incremental gain in going to
a store to buy a book versus ordering
the book from a website that you can
feel right whereas the gain of like
basically the people I see realizing the
potential of this are the people that
understand the actual backend problems
and solving and I think if other people
want to truly understand what's going on
here they they should look beyond this
model of thinking where they're looking
at well what is the magical interface
that block chains are going to make that
is going to replace the floors today's
you know is it gonna be the next mobile
no it's not gonna be the next mobile
right what its gonna be is it's gonna be
a new way that today's interfaces what
they do on the backend and so to
understand the significance of that you
have to understand where today's systems
fall short of course what's what's the
most important book you've ever read the
most important book I've ever read I
didn't I don't I don't warn you let's go
I want to know it comes top of your mind
I think probably it would have to go
back to some of the earlier books that
I've read because they probably have a
little slightly larger effect on you
than the things you read later in life
and then I would have to say it was two
of Plato's dialogues because they're
they're interrelated cuz they touched
the same point and that would be the
Protagoras and gorgeous so those those
two dialogues are early on in my life
had a certain certain effect on my
thinking about things that I think was
significant for me at least that's great
alright you can only answer with a
number Oh
no price no I don't care what price
though what is the probability that
aliens exist what are you putting it the
probability that aliens exist 100
percent 100 percent 100 - yeah come on
hundred percent yeah man all right
listen I I I always end each one with
letting the guess ask me one question
what what one question would you ask me
Wow okay let me think very quickly I
guess okay where do you think
geographically the smart contract
adoption will we'll take off I'm gonna
answer with a bad answer but it's
actually globally it's not one location
it's in multi location type transactions
so when you go across jurisdictions
across countries etc where you start to
involve multiple regulators multiple you
know jurisdictions of law etc smart
contracts can be a huge benefit so
alright man listen thank you so much for
coming this has been awesome I really
really appreciate it and obviously
you've got a very unique view of the
world and doing some great work so I
hope we can do this again in the future
you know I appreciate it thank you very
much absolutely